so herzlich willkommen zum letzten teil
unserer türkeireise ihr wisst war
mehrmals zusammen schon bei der fabrik
mit waren meine kreise fabrik haben euch
verschiedene produzenten gezeigt und
heute kommt der dritte teil
[Musik]
so in der dritten folge geht es um die
teppiche auf dieses video haben viele
viele von euch gewartet die mich in den
storage und verfolgt haben und mir schon
geschrieben haben im katalog sind
teppich auch drin
wir haben sie noch nicht freigeschaltet
jetzt vorab heute sind sie im shop auch
freigeschaltet habe hier
es gibt ein grund warum ich das mache
und zwar meine eltern kommen aus der
türkei
mein vater ist vor 13 jahren verstorben
und als ich acht jahre alt war kein mir
noch gut daran erinnern als in diesem
sommer
in den sommerferien in die türkei
geflogen sind sie mit dem bus dann
nachsehen ob gefahren das ist ungefähr
so zwölf stunden fahrt und ich hab dann
raus aufs meer geschaut und rechts waren
die berge wir sind dann wirklich diese
diese straße entlang gefahren
dann hab ich mein vater angeschaut und
habe zu meinem papa gesagt aber
irgendwann wenn ich groß bin brauche ich
den haus hier und da ein paar mich
angeschaut und hat gesagt mach das nicht
so dass das das brauche ich nicht
und dann hat er noch mal auf die küste
geschaut haben die häuser gesehen hat
mir gesagt dass murat irgendwann meine
große macht die firma und gibt diesen
menschen arbeiten damit sie hier bleiben
können und folglich muss mich jetzt noch
daran erinnern ganz krasse geschichte
ich konnte man ihn eine fabrik in der
türkei bauen und grad an der
schwarzmeerküste
die infrastruktur das werde ich auch nie
machen können mein lebensmittelpunkt
bisschen waghäusel
aber vielleicht kann ich auf eine andere
art und weise den menschen etwas gutes
tun ihnen arbeit geben und deswegen
machen wir auf der suche im netz
zusammen produzenten zu besuchen treffen
zu finden
und definitiv was für mich in die türkei
gehört sowie für euch natürlich auch was
ein computer erfüllt sind diese teppiche
wir sind mit news zusammen im
schwiegervater zusammen nach kusel
angeflogen einer istanbuler stadtteil
von islam ist an bulimie roche zusammen
und jetzt auch mal vor der kamera
und jetzt der kameramann wir eigentlich
film jetzt von ihm und anders vor der
kamera hinter der kamera passiert auch
mal genau und wir haben ihn wir haben
durch den wolken zusammen den den
südtiroler kennen
das motto und seine familie die man seit
generation schon teppichhandel die
handel mit orientteppichen und was sie
auch machen ist sie besuchen haushalte
in der türkei es gibt im türkei 20
millionen haushalte und je nach hause
eine türkei hat mindestens fünf teppich
hier also ist diese einige alles wenn
man dann nach anori sie beim 107 109 100
millionen teppichen und das tolle ist 80
prozent dieser teppich ist noch hand
geknüpft
es gibt kaum noch handgeknüpfte teppiche
auf dieser welt das heißt er geht diesen
diese haushalte kauft diesen menschen
diese teppiche ab teilweise auch kaputt
teilweise wollen sie die menschen auch
gar nicht mehr und erwartet dadurch eine
tradition weil jede region in der türkei
sei es jetzt konya sei es jetzt tue sei
es in istanbul sei es in kaiser wir
hatten andere teppichknüpfkunst mit
anderen ornamenten die meisten teppiche
heutzutage sind aus polyester ist
maschinen teppiche aber das ist richtig
handarbeit richtig natürlichkeit und
genau jeder club noch mehr haben da ist
selber gesehen
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen wollte ich
bin gerade möglich auch impressive weil
wir als als doch als deutscher wirst
jetzt zum teppichhändler ja ein bisschen
naja und am anfang hat sie noch 0
interessiert und auf der reise wenn wir
den menschen redet und weiß wie viel
arbeit dahintersteckt merken ein
geniales ist lernt man das einfach
wirklich wert zu schätzen die ganze
sache genau und das ist für mich ein
stück kultur das ist ein stück tradition
und du hast die ganzen schritte gesehen
japan bestimmt ihr werdet gleich mit 10
15 20 schritte oder noch mehr zwischen
dingen genau und es ist und das ist das
besondere wesen alle 100 prozent
natürlich da ist kein polyester drin
das ist alles eine manufaktur komplett
genau und wie das hergestellt wird
nehmt euch mal mit auf die reise mal
schauen ob wir dann nachher auch so
begeistert zeit wieder los und server
ist ein wenig verarscht dich ich habe
mich infizieren lassen denn ab jetzt
auch selber ein paar tricks habe ich von
mir zu hause und ich liebe ihn und für
mich ist es wirklich eine kultur
weiterführen und etwas ganz ganz
besonderes haben und das haben die
richtig genial gemacht und schaut euch
jetzt mal an
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir in tuzla und hier
steht das unternehmen von sword aber
hier werden die teppiche und veredelt
hier werden die teppiche alle
eingesammelt die kommen werden dann alle
nach konya geschickt in konya wenn sie
gewaschen werden sie gleicht eingefärbt
und vergleichen eingefärbt sind und die
fasern auch alle auf einer höhe getrimmt
worden worden sind kommen sie hier nach
tuzla und user werden sie komplett
veredelt und wir zusammen
zusammengebracht
da gibt es keine unterschiede zwischen
kim und zwischen halle
kim ist geht ein gelebter teppich und an
halle ist ein geknüpfte teppiche es ist
ein riesenunterschied und diese teppiche
werden hier alle zusammen gebracht und
wieder veredelt und etwas neues entsteht
daraus sagen
originalzustand gebleicht und eingefärbt
jetzt werden noch hier so kaputte sachen
so flecken noch komplett
herausgeschnitten
das thema aber oben gleich und ihr seht
es mehrere mehrere schritte bisher
richtig perfekten teppich für zuhause
hat mit einer geschichte und mit kultur
[Musik]
wenn ich hier ankommen dann wird als
allererstes hinten fliesst drauf gemacht
das ist eine ganz ganz wichtig das ist
das hier wird dieses vlies drauf gemacht
das ist das erste fliesst ist ein ganz
normales baumburg fließt und das sorgt
dafür dass wenn die teppiche
angeschnitten werden dass die ganzen
phase nicht auseinanderbrechen und der
kleber ist auch ein rein biologischer
gläser kleber da ist keine chemie dran
und danach kommt irgendwann mal das
zweite fließt auch ganz zum schluss es
sehen wir erst mal später
[Musik]
so das war jetzt der erste schritt dafür
jetzt gehen wir direkt an den 2 so jetzt
kommt ein bisschen deutsche technik mit
ins spiel
und zwar haben wir ein sap system und
ist sap system hat kunden angelegt und
diese kunden eine bestimmte größe in
unserem teppich haben und für jede größe
gibt es hier jemals das sind so müsse
sofort schließen so sowie messer und
hiermit werden die patches ausgestanzt
jungs die bühne alles ausmessen holen
die patch ist aus den regalen und voll
achtung ist saumäßig scharf die werden
also draufgelegt so wie sie hier gemacht
haben und es gibt verschiedene formen
und verschiedene größen
[Musik]
und das ist jetzt der abfall und das
tolle am abfall ist jetzt folgendes das
ist ein rein natürlicher stopp es ist
eben wie der hand baumwolle ziegenhaar
und hinten der tische aufbauen wolle
das wird komplett wiederverwertet und
jetzt gibt es diese verschiedenen
patches wo nachher zusammengenäht werden
jetzt gehen wir an die dritte station
und da zeigt auch was dort gemacht wird
gehen alle da jedes kleine stück wird
wiederverwendet
das war s kennern aber hier macht er
macht es nur eine kleine version der
macht diese kleinen patches und diese
kleinen patchen patches die werden für
matten gemacht für tomaten oder für für
kissenbezüge gibt es auch ganz ganz
coole kissenbezüge aus teppichen oder
mixa diese fußmatten
[Musik]
nachdem die patches ausgestanzt worden
sind sind sie noch ziemlich instabil ihn
sich die nebel macht hier nochmal in
kompletten overlack und ist komplett aus
damit es auch richtig stabil ist und das
macht die in einer atemberaubenden
geschwindigkeit
[Musik]
die zahlreichen großes maul gehabt
schwiegervater jetzt die immer gespannt
er kann es auch nehmen wir mal kein pc
via familie
ja denn es sind so jetzt immer gespannt
was das spiel ist schneller
schwiegervater ist schön mit dem sakko
hier papa jetzt mal gespannt ob er was
verlernt hat lange sehr 30 jahre hast du
dort gearbeitet hat natürlich wäre 30
jahre geschätzt 40 jahre jetzt
übertreibt aber zu 100 löslich gespannt
[Musik]
so aber er ist nicht schlecht muss ich
sagen aber nicht schlecht
nur mit dir drei tage und der laden hier
pleite glaube ich eher nicht erst einmal
da ist durch sagt jahre lang gemacht ja
bin ich nicht in maschine arbeitet aber
über das okay da gehen wir weiter an die
vierte station so der nächste schritt
ist natürlich nach dem oberloh
einsortieren nach farbe nach nach größe
nach vorn in all die ganzen regale hier
im raum
[Musik]
das lehrt zum beispiel mein favorit
richtig schön alles in schwarz wird auch
richtig toll kommt der hier ist aus der
russisch aus unserer rustikal kollektion
und das ist für mich auch tradition so
müssten hellwig aussehen diese lila
kollektion das war der wunsch meiner
frau
der hat das richtig gut gefallen und es
ist auch richtig toll aus jeder teppich
ist nicht nur vom muster und von der
farbe individuell sondern kann auch von
der größe individuell sein
hier ist zum beispiel die größe 2 70 auf
3 metern das hat sich ein kunde
gewünscht und so kommen bei uns zum
beispiel auch die typischen wir stellen
helaba und halle
die machen jetzt die komposition das ist
jetzt wie so ein musikstück und diesem
musikstück heißt einfach hier die farben
und die formen im einklang zu bringen
zum beispiel stück weg und sagt okay was
passt besser oder nicht und da müsse
schon ein richtiges auge dafür
[Musik]
und dann geht s dann runter in die
veredelung des den teppich zusammen zu
nehmen
und zwar was macht alle macht den
sechsten schritt ihr habt da oben
gesehen oben wurden über diese nummern
drauf geklebt und er tut es jetzt alles
zusammen sollen also zusammennähen
sozusagen als eine bahn
so sieht es aus es war das
zusammengenäht und von hier aus geht's
jetzt zum bügeln ja es werden die bäume
werden zusammen gebügelt hier sind
glücks allawi und der glücks la vie
macht eigenen nächste schritte haben
alle der siebte schritt und zwar für
alle hatte hierzu alles zusammen genäht
und der wechsel aber tut jetzt bügeln
das tue ich daheim auch immer ich bügele
gern überaus gerne ich liebe ihn über
alles
[Musik]
folgendes wenn der wechsel zum beispiel
kein strom hätte es kann auch passieren
istanbul dass ich mal die zeit lang
keinen strom aus und er hat kein
bügeleisen dann nehmt ihr den löffel und
macht es per hand ich habe daheim auch
schon ein paar hemden dem löffel
gebügelt habe ich auch schon gemacht
da lachen sie da hinten so dass ich das
getan habe und er tat nimmt jetzt die
ganzen rollen und näht sie noch mal
zusammen cannabis den nächsten geschickt
hast nur nicht verlieren müssen
der ist wenn der fan mache ich
normalerweise gar nicht welche taschen
egal
[Musik]
jörg adler aus germany die maschine dann
gibt es da noch happy sind auch aus
germany und hier sind wir beim
qualitätscheck dass man die frauen hier
einen qualitätscheck weil sie einfach
das auge dafür haben und weil sie es
können
hier wird noch mal alles kontrolliert ob
der saal sitzt ob irgendwelche fäden
rausschauen und gegebenfalls wird
nachgebessert genial
[Musik]
ihr habt ihr gesehen
der erste schritt war ja schon baumwolle
fließt drauf zu machen und jetzt machen
sie sich jetzt kleben doch im zweiten
lauf
und wie gesagt es ist normalerweise als
kunde gar nicht aber hier wird wirklich
gemacht also wenn ich irgendwann mal
kaputt bekommt dann weiß ich was ich
nicht gemacht habt weil das ist
eigentlich fast schon unmöglich und es
ist ein ganz krasses qualitätskriterium
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt unser teppich aus
unserem wohnzimmer den rainbow den gibt
es auch bei uns genial oder wow wow so
hier liegt an unserem rainbow teppich
und der kern aber hat ein bisschen high
tech im spiel und zwar sind hier immer
die ganz genau und größen von den ganzen
teppichen aufgezeichnet er legt jetzt
diesen teppich hin und schneiden genau
auf maß dh 3 50 auf 3 50 2 20 auf 370
wie auch immer und diese kleinen roboter
hier die schneiden jetzt alles bis auf
eine toleranz von zwei zentimetern so
das ist die bilder und die kinder dabei
nach dem schneiden macht sie noch ein
richtig overlack zone sie versäumt ist
sozusagen komplett den ganzen teppich
damit dem test ist
[Musik]
und man hier fängt schon qualität an
manche machen nur diese versorgung und
verkaufen diese teppiche
aber das ist hier um ein
qualitätsprodukt handelt kommt noch
dieser baseballs tisch
[Musik]
und er macht jetzt da alle richtig
genial
[Applaus]
jetzt wurde dieser baseballs tisch
gemacht und jetzt kommt etwas was euch
bestimmte hat zu hause auch schon
passiert es bei dem teppich und zwar
oftmals ist es so dass die ecken ist
sich nach oben wird nun darüber stolpert
wie bei dinner for one
da war es zwar ein bär glaube ich aber
meistens ist so dass wir die kante ist
oder die ecke ist und was sie jetzt
machen was auch ein qualitätsmerkmal
die machen jetzt einen stich und zwar
nicht in ecken sticht die beschwerden
diese ecken dass diese ecke flach auf
dem boden sind und dass man nicht drüber
gestolpert und dann macht es übrigens an
einer pfaff die kommt aus kaiserslautern
aber ich glaube es unternehmen gibt es
nicht mehr
die haben so gut die maschinen
hergestellt dass die dass man hat
mehrere neue kaufen müssen und ich
glaube das war der nähe untergangen das
heißt wenn du zu viel zu gut die
maschinen herstellt ist es auch nichts
großes glaube ich jetzt gesehen vorne
war nochmal eine qualitätskontrolle und
es ist wieder eine und zwar jetzt
überprüfen sie gerade die stiche ob die
in ordnung sind irgendwelche farbfehler
sind und die messen in teppich noch mal
per hand aus damit er genau die richtige
größe hat und ja nicht zu groß ist oder
zu klein
[Applaus]
derzeit existiert damit auch fällig wenn
die mädels die qualitätskontrolle
gemacht haben und hier geht der teppich
darunter ins lager und das ist ein
stockwerk weiter unten und vom lager aus
würde zu uns versendet und das schauen
wir uns recht
[Musik]
so jetzt habt ihr mal gesehen wie so
eine produktion von so einem patchwork
teppich wirklich stattfindet was ist
besondere ist was die qualitätsmerkmale
sind jeder teppich ist was besonderes
zeigt die kultur die tradition der
verschiedenen regionen der türkei
und das ist etwas ganz ganz besonderes
es ist mir wirklich bewusst dass sich
nicht jeder so ein teppich leisten kann
wirklich aber es geht darum dass wir
wissen dass es sowas gibt dieser teppich
ist nicht billig aber er ist günstig und
zwar oder besser gesagt preiswert weil
dieser teppich ist seien preiswert und
ihr könnt diese teppich bei uns
bestellen bei uns auf dem shop das ding
und nur sein die lieferung dauert vier
bis fünf wochen
weil ihr die größe vorgibt ihr gibt es
die seien vor und diese dann extra für
euch hergestellt und das ist das
besondere daran es ist nicht einfach nur
ein produkt es ist wirklich eine
tradition die hier weitergegeben wird
ihr habt die menschen kennengelernt
denen die maschinen stehen und das war
mir einfach wichtig und vielleicht seht
ihr jetzt manche teppich auch mit einem
ganz ganz anderen augen und zählt auch
die besonderheiten dran und jetzt würde
ich gerne noch ein paar modelle zeigen
und auch mal so ein teppich der
qualitativ nicht hochwertig ist das seht
ihr als endverbraucher nicht die hier
sehen das und die haben mich das höchste
maß an qualität in das produkt gebracht
was sage ich geben kann und das schauen
wir uns jetzt mal an
okay das da hier ist zum beispiel so ein
fake teppich der sieht von außen sieht
er aus wie die originalen nur hier seht
ihr hier haben sie den ersten schritt
komplett ausgelassen
hier seht ihr zum beispiel den tätig wo
hier hergestellt wird so sieht ja normal
aus dann kommt die erste stich wird
beklebt und die zweite schicht auch und
hier wurde die komplette erste schicht
komplett weggelassen
das sorgt dafür dass sich der teppich
nachher so verhalten bildet das nach
richtige verhalten richtige stolper
bildungen drin
und hier wurde einfach ab so eine
qualität gespart das andere ist wenn er
hier nicht verklebt ist dann kannst du
richtig nachher die ganzen fäden
rausziehen kannst du richtig raus ziehen
und so ein teppich hätte auch nicht
lange und das sind diese filme hier
wohnen auf dem markt gibt und wo die
leute nachher vergleichen wir müssen wir
kämpfen immer mit äpfeln vergleichen und
birnen mit birnen und das ist der hammer
qualität einmal verklebt einmal verklebt
zweimal verklebt perfekt
der teppich ist auch was ganz ganz
besonderes sind alle besonders am
liebsten durch alle mitnehmen
ganz ehrlich das ist auch richtig cool
der wurde dann wirklich nur für uns
hergestellt wirklich abschied für uns
dann eine besonderheit und zwar ist sie
der rücken zb in unserem pink und auch
hier diese diese pinken knöpfe hier
drauf oder diese karrees und dieser
teppich der ist inspiriert von der zeit
der seldschuken der ist wie soll ich
sagen
irgendwas geschichtliches ist ein
teppich hatte mir gerade auf türkisch
erklärt ich kann es auch deutlich
übersetzen aber genial
[Musik]
und bevor die teppich auf reise gehen
bekommen noch so einen coolen sally
patch jetzt kommt noch der letzte
schnitt schritt meine ich
doch das ist jetzt mein tätig der geht
es nach deutschland nach österreich in
die schweiz eine tradition weitergeführt
ich jetzt pulsiert inventar laut ich
mein eigener tätig
[Musik]
infos oben ich habe das sagen so jetzt
bin ich hier habt den teppich gebracht
und so sieht's aus und ich finde der
teppich der bringt hier einfach klar
farbe mit ryanair bringt aber auch
dieses gemütliche mit rein wenn man
jetzt nämlich mal die bilder vergleicht
von vorher und nachher vorher warteraum
zwar auch schön und großzügig unter
beton wurden gefällt mir auch sehr gut
aber der teppich der verein zur die
mögliche drin
der bringt dieses wohlige wohlfühlgefühl
mit hier rein genug war so ein rosigkeit
ja und auch die farben und vor allem hat
mich einfach kunterbunt gewählt das
heißt wir können das wohnzimmer immer
dekorieren wie wir möchten
denn es passt einfach immer da zu
ungenau um minimalen fleck habt sieht
man gar nicht mehr
ja und für uns der spielteppich sagt
spielteppich das ist der teppich auch
ein spielteppich denn mit den kindern
machen wir immer das spielen wer streng
zuerst auf die farbe blau rot und auch
wir sind totale eyecatcher denn ganz
ehrlich musste ich eben sein geschmack
sein
manche mögen es vielleicht nur ein paar
rot oder ihm in petrol oder nur pink
oder wie auch immer andere farben aber
ich finde einfach hier sieben nochmal
die verschiedenheit des teppichs
niederrhein kommt der fragt nach dem
teppich also jeder dass daher rein und
sagt hey krass was ist das für ein
teppich genau und dem büro sieht da
nämlich dann so aus dass so ein bisschen
klassischer an im esszimmer genau da ein
bisschen grünlich genommen wurde und im
kinderzimmer bei der lh sieht das so aus
als ich finde überall sieht er einfach
etwas anders aus und will diesen teppich
übrigens wenn ihr aus der nähe von
mannheim kommt könnt ihr uns ja dem q 6
q 7 in unserem store besuchen denn da
geht es dir teppiche auch da können sie
mal anfassen und anschauen und die
farbpracht sehen also ich finde da muss
man schon auch mal zur live gesehen
haben und vor allem später in haufen
kultur und auch haufen tradition
dahinter handwerk in riesen handwerk und
100 prozent natürlich alles komplett mit
mir komplett handmade hat mit hand
genäht gestrickt gehäkelt und so ein up
seidling das heißt wir erhalten die
textile kette die alten teppiche werden
nicht weggeschmissen sondern einfach
recycelt und einfach neu hergestellt
also neu zusammengestellt das video hat
mich gefreut war eine tolle geschichte
auch new york zusammen die türkei zu
reisen
waren unter anderen mit er ist denkt
immer geht es nicht mehr die türkei
sally ist auch nächste bei dem mal mit
denen hier nach einem lokalen
produzenten der ausschuss produziert ja
das wird noch geheim aber wie gesagt das
nächste im internet ist wieder in
deutschland
und dann gehen wir irgendwann nach
spanien das tor ist ihm auch mit wenig
keramik und ja ja kein vielen dank
schreibt uns gerne in die kommentare wie
ihr das video endet wie ihr die teppiche
findet und ich hoffe wir sehen uns ganz
bald wieder wachstum macht das echt gut
danke schön war lustig nicht so einfach
so weil die mutter schaut zu
deswegen gehen wir jetzt getrennte wege
ich möchte mir gesagt hat ja den gegner
hat immer gesagt dass ich aus wie ein
teppich verkäufer jetzt mich auf einer
geworden also ganz ohne spaß ist aber
dass echte hat und wie die nennt mich
nicht teppichverkäufer kein fan ich
verkäufer aber echt genial dass der witz
was für das wissen wir ja was ist
nächste was ich nächstes mal irgendwie
autos verkaufen es geht wirklich ich
finde es einfach nur genial leute zu ihm
ist kein teppich kaufen absolut nicht
mir ist nur wichtig dass ich mal sehen
wie das alles funktioniert wie das hier
abläuft was die geschichte dahinter ist
dass mir ist wichtig wo ihr euren
täglich kauft ist mir nicht schnuppe
absolut aber das ist mit nicht genial